the great reddit hack for the store we
got from wired
and i looked at a bunch of these news
stories hackers flood reddit with
pro-trump takeovers
by apparently compromising moderator
accounts the attackers were able to post
manga materials all over at least 70
popular subreddits the only problem
is they're clearly not pro-trump they're
like
caricatures of trump mocking his ideas
and it's written in chinese
partly hmm that's shady
so well so here's here's the interesting
thing though so
these hacks have happened we'll we'll
get into it but it reeks of a psi
actually let me read this so you can get
some context first and then i want to
break this down because this could be
this actually could be pro-trump people
trying to frame
china trying to frame them you know it
could be a weird
good point you know who knows well
here's what wired says
in what appears to be a massive
coordinated strike against reddit
hackers took over dozens of pages on
friday afternoon
using their access to plaster pro donald
trump imagery
across subreddits with huge followings
coming just over three weeks after
hackers
used access to high uh to used after
hackers
used access to high profile twitter
accounts to tweet a bitcoins
wired what are you talking about the
wave of reddit compromises has similar
eye-popping reach
reddit communities with well over a
million members including r space
food nfl were defaced with maga campaign
banners and other pro-trump
signage now the interesting thing is
you know what man i've i just can't it's
it's so difficult i need to start a news
organization
yes you do so we can actually fix these
stories first of all
the the the high profile bitcoin scam
like come on man get you got to be more
it was it was way worse than that
just to make it seem like some bitcoin
scam happened like after the president
and the vice president accounts were
hacked
and also mentioned what seems to be
pro-trump accounts but it's actually
written in chinese they even mentioned
look at this
we stand with donald trump mica
micah2020 what was what does that mean
sometime on friday morning hackers began
breaking into the accounts of the
moderators
uh they used that access not only to
splash pro-trump imagery all over the
page
but in many cases posted a maga missive
from the moderator's account with a
subject we stand with donald trump
miga 2020. we on behalf of the american
people
want to implore and strongly encourage
you all to vote trump in 2020 elections
of the usa of the usa of america
and there are are they seriously gonna
gonna talk about what is this
read one such message these are somebody
wired doesn't have a copy editor i think
because this is all just
really awful but maybe that's literally
what the words were
verbatim you know no no no no i'm saying
that makes sense because if it's
translated from from chinese and they
might have not been saying
the wired article itself was written in
chinese first no this is in quotes so
maybe
this part i'm highlighting isn't oh read
one such oh read one such message
period uh period or comma but they're
like not capitalizing they're missing
words oh okay
i see what you're saying yeah yeah all
right opposed to a college football
focused r
cfb the post goes on to call the novel
chronovirus a hoax
loosely compares trump to batman and
ends with a list of 10 things democrats
did wrong
which includes nice people are hated by
the democrats as a bullet point
in the case of r cfb the hackers also
took the community to private
leaving only an emoji strewn pro-trump
message on the landing page for those
locked out
an investigation is underway related to
a series of vandalized communities said
a reddit spokesperson
it appears the source of the attacks
were compromised moderator accounts we
are still working to lock down those
accounts
and restore impacted communities they
say hackers attempted to claim
to to claim credit for the attacks on
twitter saying we combined password
stuffing and social engineering together
to beat the teenage bitcoin cheater an
apparent reference to the you know the
twitter hack
uh the twitter ringleader i guess graham
ivan clark they say who was arrested
last week
credential stuffing is when the attacker
uses previously leaked passwords to
break into accounts
made by the same email address taking
advantage of the common human tendency
to reuse passwords
social engineering is a catch-all way is
a catch-all for ways to trick people
into giving you information as we get
claims of hacking claims of hacking
credit on twitter
should be taken with hefty boulders of
assault but some combination of password
reuse and sim swapping could certainly
be at the heart of the reddit hacks
since the takeovers occurred wait what
since the
okay reddit users have been scrambling
to figure out what happened and to
protect their own accounts
a post published friday afternoon by a
reddit community moderator warns people
to look for unexpected password reset
emails
and encourages mods to change their
passwords
i actually got one of these really yeah
i did
i didn't think anything of it i don't i
don't have any subreddits or anything
so i think what happened was somebody
you tried using one of my emails
for some reason and i i got some weird
notification
yeah but there's there's nothing i don't
know if they're gonna i don't moderate
any subreddits or anything like that
so anyway i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
get too much into the rest of what they
say because they have no idea what
they're talking about but they show this
image right here
yeah this is a terrible article it just
says like the maga messaging is less
disturbing than the hacker's ability to
pull it off blah blah blah
they're not even telling you what the
images are look at this what is this
what
this is one of the things they posted
that's what does it mean
i don't know and it and it's clearly
it's somebody wrote something in chinese
so we have this watch it's like a bunch
of swears that we just put up
yeah maybe i don't know what it means
who knows what it is
so subreddit drama tracked all of the
different subreddits that got hit by
this
and the funny thing about their messages
is that they
they believe it like look at this this
comment says i wonder if anyone's like
quote
i wasn't going to vote for trump before
but now that his supporters hacked the
accounts of the mods of r
naruto i will
do they really think sure do they really
think that's what happened
maybe this this really look i don't i
don't know exactly what happened but
i'll tell you what look at this this is
part of the match i can't read any of
this for all i know
look at this goya bean for all i know
this is a bunch of slurs and swears i
guess
magoya america lyric american lyrics in
best country language
here are 10 things democrats did right
nothing they suck it's
it looks like it's written by someone
who speaks chinese yeah and has second
language english
or like a bot or just however had it
translated and didn't understand how to
fix
to make it you know correct right it
could be however
somebody wrote in english translate it
to chinese and then back to english
so that it seems like it was chinese 4d
chess
yeah man or maybe it was
chinese hackers like what what does it
matter like
you know who who do they think or what
is it what is the point of it
what what are they getting out of this
well already a lot of people think trump
supporters did this
why why do they think trump supporters
no no no why would tr
why would trump supporters dig up weird
chinese versions of what they would wire
didn't say that
wired just said trump pro-trump messages
were hacked onto
these reddit accounts right and now
you're going to be seeing a bunch of
these lefties posting saying like
these people must be stopped they're
insane and they're not going to know
anything about the context
so we look at this and we can clearly
see like i really don't think trump
supporters are writing chinese
no and it comes right after donald trump
targeted this massive company tencent oh
yeah
now of course if you hop over to the
donald dot win
they straight up say the top comment
anarchist false flag alert
yup this happened immediately after
announcing the tencent ban for a reason
and they go on to say you know nsa or
soft sabotage whatever the point is the
top comment on the donald forum which is
now
separate from reddit the donald.win
they're saying it's a false flag
yep and i think that makes sense because
you end up with people saying things
like
one of the comments is why can't trump
supporters just leave us alone
and people believe it yes they do and
i'm willing to bet if you go on reddit
now it's not even about whether they
believe it
you know there's going to be these far
lefties who use this
they weaponize this and they're going to
say did you see what those trump
supporters did the other day
they like took over and vandalized a
whole bunch of forums for sports and
games
one of one of the comments was talking
just about this specifically about the
motive for trump supporters
and they said why would trump supporters
hack all these subreddits and the
response is
you need to what they said was that you
need to understand that trump supporters
don't care about winning they care about
mocking you for having no power
they want to show you they're more
powerful than you and they want to laugh
while they do it
that's just a silly ridiculous way to
look at what's going on
when you consider all of the chinese
messages and all these things popping up
yeah i mean it makes more sense to me
that
i mean this this whole 10 cent thing
could could
ruin spotify could ruin league of
legends
fortnite is in the crosshairs like we
don't know the implications of how it's
going to change
these online games that i mean
you really think about who's playing it
10 years old to like 30 year olds like
that that's a huge base in these games
so if suddenly like they can't play it
anymore or they get cut off from from
that game
that's that's insane so so they might
like
i don't know who it is but i have
there's no doubt in my mind it's not
trump supporters
right i think that or that it's trump
supporters i i doubt it completely
you're saying it's not trump
it's it's not trump supporters there's
no way i
it reeks of a chinese psyop true it
could it it could theoretically be like
i don't know people in hong kong who
like trump
right it could be some dumb kids who
don't care either way we really don't
doubt that i doubt that there's some
dumb kids think it's funny
i doubt that it's just some dumb kids i
mean right after he's banning
wechat and 10 cent he's coming down on
on china
you know it's like all these these
little things like the executive order
about hong kong
leading up to now it's like you put
those two together now you know where he
can
halt uh seize assets if you're if you're
connected to
any one of these things now add this
into the play you could seize the assets
of all these companies
exactly it's crazy like you think about
it if he connects it then they
like the us government can seize the
assets of anyone aiding
the chinese government in reference to
hong kong
true but because they're all doing it
exactly
so trump's trump issued an executive
order that was basically like if you
mess with hong kong
we can like freeze your assets yeah the
only thing is it was so
vague you can basically be like this guy
is a baker
who provided a cake to the wedding of
this guy who's in the mail room of the
chinese communist party
who works you know in the party
therefore
and that's that's it he can sanction the
baker and who else who else is going
after
big pharma he just gave a big fu to big
pharma now he's hiding yeah now he's
hiding i mean he just
he literally just said yesterday i have
very rich enemies who don't like what
i'm doing
with this going after china and going
after big pharma has been milking
americans
like he's basically saying if a drug is
only three dollars over in mexico
and they're charging through 400 in
america it's now illegal to do that
you have to charge the same as what it
is in mexico so
big pharma is taking a huge cut checking
anyone that's got ties to china has
taken a big hit this is the craziest
thing about the medicine because i was
arguing with some people about universal
health care earlier
trying to point out that universal
health care needs to have a limit
somewhere where like what's the level of
care you can provide
and then what level of care is covered
by private insurance yeah but of course
you know bernie and them were like uh
you know they want to abolish private
insurance all together that would make
it impossible for certain treatments to
get to certain people so it's kind of a
weird idea
yeah but like anyway i don't want to get
too much of that but i was like you know
the president just said
we should have lower prices we shouldn't
you know we shouldn't have
you know in canada it's 50 cents and
here it's you know 50
or more but i can't get any of these
lefties to actually admit
that trump is offering something better
than joe biden is
in these areas yeah and if you think
about it it's like we're basing the
price of universal healthcare on the
current system
right so like if these drugs cost three
grand
per person where in canada it's 50 bucks
you know the the system that we're we're
calculating it is
for the three thousand dollars to go to
these middlemen that are getting money
off that system
so if you if you change the whole math
to to make it so it's the new price it
it becomes significantly easier
your argument is still true though i
agree with there's always going to be
some
you know diseases that are way too much
money millions of dollars yeah because
it's there's only
you know 100 people a year 100 patients
that could be cured by it if right if
that
so you might need a specialist who gets
paid a ridiculous you know some which
requires decades of training right
and then you might need like you know
the bark of the
the uh gorbo tree from the deep within
the amazon forest which hits atop the
mountain of
valerian whatever yeah this isn't like
2050 where we got gorbo rooms
right where you can just go in and grab
a little bit of gorbo and you're
saved so there's research there's labor
and there's things involved
yeah and so you know you look at you
look at joe biden he's a disaster you
look at donald trump and he's doing
things and he's talking about things
that are
are are better for a lot of these
progressives for americans
yeah but but there's a lot of people who
just live off tribalism
their whole their whole shtick is you
know i'm on this team therefore you're
bad
yeah and there's there's like there's
like three teams basically
you know there's there's the far left
who hates everybody else
there are the democrats who hate trump
but will use the far left when they can
and then there's like the bigger tent of
y'all are crazy
you know so i think like yeah the the
bigger tent has liberals moderates
conservatives libertarians
all saying yo you you guys are losing
your minds
yeah democrats are mad with power and
the far left is trying to they're both
using each other i think the far left is
better off with trump because it clears
that it clears out the establishment we
talked about this yesterday
but take a look at this story but they
won't they won't ever see it that way
because they've got it in their brain
npcs and that tds is way too strong for
them yeah
they're they're non-play non-player
characters yeah they say things that
make no sense they have no idea what
they're talking about
i was trying to talk to somebody and
they started insulting me and i'm like
i'm like bro i'm like trying to agree
with you on universal
you know basic health care right why are
you insulting me
and then they're just like oh i don't
know i'm like yeah it's a good it's i'm
what like they made a post about
universal health care i was like here's
a way i think we can do it and they were
like
oh my you know you're so dumb blah blah
blah and i'm like you know what man
they don't actually want to have a
conversation step down from your
emotions
yeah they're just angry and so i think
they they attach these tribal
identifiers like i believe in these
things not because they truly understand
it
yeah but because it's their team colors
like i'm for
these things i have no idea how many
this works so therefore i'll insult
anybody who questions it
even if you're like in agreement like i
wonder what can we do in this regard
they're like
f you you're dumb okay thanks for
checking out this clip from the tim cast
irl podcast
we do the show live monday through
friday at 8pm if you want to catch the
full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you